you are not afraid to speak your mind
and you are quite vocal when you're
unhappy with a co-workers appearance or
someone's appearance like Simon Cowell
you you've worked with Simon Cowell and
you've been very outspoken about his
appearance it doesn't look good
no it amazes me that a man that is you
know he's everywhere no not so much
nowadays my goodness however just a
little blow dart in the back yeah it
anyway um his appearance for 14 years
all we've ever seen him in is a white
t-shirt and blue jeans and silly Cuban
Hill shoes it's like 14 years it's like
there's nothing of a change here right
and his face is so full of filler and
Botox it's like he just doesn't move
like me you know that proves up wait oh
so you're saying you're admitting that
you have some you've got some oh shut up
Conan you know
do not my that's watching tonight and I
am and I do not lie you look gorgeous
you look beautiful sometimes I can tell
when people get worked on and II will
tell me because he gets to see behind he
gets if I didn't go I can look at the
back and I can see all the pulleys oh
yeah yeah all the scars no but um but
you're saying that you've had some work
done how do you know that Simon Cowell's
had it done yeah actually one thing I
have to admire him for is that he admits
it he's quite open about it and he says
to quote him it's the same as having
your teeth whitened why not it's what
people do and I agree with him but
there's a point where it just gets like
like stop yeah you said you compared him
you said he looked like a pickled onion
a [ __ ] around and firm yeah but like you
think that he's used so much filler he
looks like a pickled onion we're gonna
put the two side-by-side you tell me
what you think I don't know I'm not sure
I see it yes I see it
Darryl good go hey thanks for watching
be sure to click subscribe to see even
more great Conan clips you may now
return to your pirated movies and creepy
Japanese pornography